ich hoffe die aussprache der teile als
erster interessent der kollegin sylvia
kotting-uhl bündnis 90 die grünen das
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen elfter märz
2011 dreifach katastrophe in japan
erdbeben tsunami und in der folge ein
atomarer gau im atomkraftwerk fukushima
daiichi der tsunami tötete 20.000
menschen ihrer wird in japan in diesen
tagen gedacht und zu beginn unserer
debatte heute möchte ich mein mitgefühl
nach japan senden und meine
verbundenheit mit den menschen dort
ausdrücken 20.000 tode durch den tsunami
470.000 menschen die verstrahlten
gebiete verlassen wollten mussten
ich glaube in übergroßer mehrheit sind
wir uns hier im bundestag einig dass wir
die missionen von leid nicht abwägen
japan ist ein äußerst technikaffine
island das wahrsagen seine atomtechnik
eine nationale kränkung weshalb die
japanische regierung die atomkraft immer
noch als teil der energieversorgung will
nicht aber die getroffenen präfektur
fukushima die hat den atomausstieg
beschlossen
auch nachbarkommunen der atomkraftwerke
verhindern mit ihrem mitspracherecht den
gewünschten atomstromanteil für das
japanische energieministerium
funktioniert die rechnung auch nur weil
es die hunderte milliarden folgekosten
für den gau konsequent von den kosten
des atomstroms abspaltet zehn jahre nach
dem gau von fukushima gibt es immer noch
menschen
parteien und länder die dem atom
lobbyismus erleben der verlorenen glanz
soll mit der durch suggestion einer
billigen klimaschützenden sauber und
energie wieder aufpoliert werden
der realität halten solche behauptungen
nicht stand ein akw neubau ein akw
neubau mit angemessenen
sicherheitsstandards ist unter zehn
milliarden nicht zu haben die
kilowattstunde strom kostet über zehn
cent eine heute installierte
photovoltaikanlage liefert strom für
unter 5 cent auf der suche nach neuen
förderquellen für atomkraft fanden die
lobbyisten die taxonomie und den
wasserstoff die atomenergie als
nachhaltige geldanlage und gelber
wasserstoff den grünen an die seite
gestellt
wg gedacht aber auch fade und nachhaltig
an der atomkraft ist vor allem der müll
der uns über eine million jahre pflicht
nimmt und die gern bemühte co2 armut des
atomstroms entlarvt sich schnell wenn
wir die kette von uran abbau bis zur
endlagerung in den blick nehmen den
vergleich mit erneuerbaren strom welt
atomstrom nicht nur bei den kosten
sondern auch beim co2 fußabdruck nicht
aus der klimaschutz stellen braucht
erneuerbare und wer erneuerbare nicht
als nische will muss ich von
grundlastkraftwerken verabschieden von
kohle und atom
trotzdem trotzdem wird mancher nicht
müde eine renaissance der atomkraft
herbeizureden was sagt die realität
nicht einmal die hälfte der
eu-mitgliedstaaten den atomstrom in der
zukunft schauen wir in die welt stellen
wir fest dass 50 neubauplänen 190
abschaltungen gegenüberstehen die zahl
in betrieb befindliche atomkraftwerke
verlängert sich beständig das heißt in
dieser frage ist die welt viel
vernünftig
als manchen gefällt atomstrom wird sich
in diesem jahrhundert erledigt haben
wo es nicht die einsicht in das risiko
ist oder in die letztliche unlösbar kite
des atommüllproblems wird es die
ökonomische vernunft seien zu teuer ist
ein argument und bill gates kann irren
aber auch wenn das herbeireden einer
renaissance der atomkraft am ende nicht
erfolgreich sein wird richtet es schaden
an
es verzögert die globale energiewende
und damit erfolgreichen klimaschutz es
verschlingt ressourcen und verlängere
das risiko und deshalb zum schluss meine
bitte an die bundesregierung
kehren sie zurück zu der kraftvollen
haltung von 2011 als deutschland
parteiübergreifend den atomausstieg
beschloss vervollständigen sie ihn mit
der schließung der atomfabriken bei uns
die das sogar globale atom karussell
antragen in den trevi sie meine worte an
die bundesregierung der präsident werden
sie nachbarländern gegenüber deutlich
bei laufzeitverlängerungen und
neubauplänen und schweigen sie nicht in
der eu wenn es um neue förderquellen für
atomkraft geht das sind sie und wir alle
dem elften märz 2011 schuldig contento
wenn ich sie auf die redezeit hinweisen
ist das kleine bösartigkeit sondern das
ist dann für alle anderen reden eine
benachteiligung mit 40 sekunden
überziehen und die anderen waren nicht
dann zur ordnung deshalb wie gesagt
keine böswilligkeit sollen dann dezenter
hinweis nächste redner dass der kollege
karsten möring cdu csu fraktion
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen vor zehn jahren hat ein
erdbeben einen tsunami in japan
ausgelöst da eine große katastrophe zur
folge hatte mit vielen tausend toten
aber wir gedenken dieser toten heute die
frau kotting-uhl gesagt hat aber wir
gedenken ihrer nicht wegen der größe
dieses tsunamis
dann müssten wir das bei dem viel
größeren unglück 2004 auch tun gegen
naturgewalten ist niemand gefeit
aber dieses ereignis hatte eine andere
katastrophe zur folge die nichts mit
einer naturgewalt zu tun hat sondern die
zurück geht auf menschliches versagen
die katastrophe der zerstörung mehrerer
kernkraftwerke in fukushima mit der
folge nicht von tausenden von toten aber
von hunderttausenden von vertriebenen
die aus ihrer heimat zurück die aus
ihrer heimat fort mussten und bis heute
in provisorischen unterkünften leben
ohne aussicht darauf in ihre heimat
zurückkehren zu können
es ist ja nicht so dass dieses ereignis
überraschend kam
das hat eine lange vorgeschichte von
vielen anderen unglücken
ich erinner mal an harrisburg 1979 mit
einer teil kernschmelze in tschernobyl
noch ein viel größeres unglück 1986
und dann fukushima im jahr 2011 und in
allen fällen hatten wir als ursache
menschliches versagen in verschiedenster
form und was ein fukushima so besonders
war ist eben die tatsache dass es sich
um ein hochtechnologie land handelt dass
eine ingenieurkunst beherrscht die
unserer gleichgestellt ist und trotzdem
führt es zu einer solchen zu einem
solchen unglück wo man sich hinterher
fragt wieso wenn man so etwas an der
küste baut rechnet man nicht damit dass
so etwas passieren kann und das ist
unser problem wir sind offensichtlich
nicht in der lage alle varianten so zu
durchdenken und auszuschließen dass wir
eine technologie tatsächlich ein hohes
risiko birgt nicht unter kontrolle
halten können mit hinreichender
sicherheit welche schlussfolgerungen hat
die welt haben wir aus diesem ereignis
gezogen
die welt hat daraus die schlussfolgerung
gezogen dass die ansprüche an
kernreaktoren immer höher geschraubt
wurden was die sicherheit angeht was zur
folge hat dass sie immer teurer wurden
ob die rechnung von frauke pinguins
genauso stimmt oder ungefähr nicht
schnitt gar keine rolle
die größenordnung der stromerzeugung
kosten durch diese kernkraft ist in eine
dimension angewachsen die nicht
konkurrenzfähig ist vor allen dingen
nicht wenn man den lebenszyklus einer
solchen anlage vor augen hat wir haben
daraus die schlussfolgerung gezogen aus
der stromerzeugung durch kernenergie
auszusteigen und am ende dieses jahres
werden wir diesen ausstieg vollendet
denn dann wird das letzte kernkraftwerk
in deutschland abgeschaltet
jetzt legen die grünen aus diesem anlass
sie einen entwurf einen antrag vor
ich will auf die ziele die forderungen
im einzelnen nicht eingehen aber es hat
mich erschüttert um es mal wirklich so
auszudrücken was in den überlegungen
dazu hier zu papier gebracht worden ist
da wird ein bestimmter typus von
menschen angesprochen der offensichtlich
empfänglich dafür ist mit kernkraft
strom zu erzeugen und da wird eine
verbindung hergestellt dass dieser typus
von mensch macht und unabhängigkeit hoch
stellte er glaubt durch atomenergie zu
erwerben
eine andere stelle lobbyisten und länder
die sich von diesen haben einfangen
lassen versuchen die atomenergie weiter
zu schreiben
liebe kollegen von den grünen also
solche psychologischen überlegungen
mögen ja richtig oder falsch seien aber
ist ihnen eigentlich klar dass sie damit
unsere nachbarländer für doof erklären
wieso durch das sind die argumente die
wir in loitz
schon zusagen machen diese politik dass
die den ich auch machen das sind unsere
nachbarn und freunde in frankreich in
england in noch in holland in polen wo
auch immer in usa die sind doch nicht so
blöd die haben doch ein grund und sie
haben eine andere bewertung als wir sie
machen aber wir sind doch nicht die
besserwisser der welt wie die welt
geglückt müssen mit dem was wir machen
die andere das genauso machen lassen
müssen damit wir zufrieden sind
wir haben souveräne ländern und wir
haben natürlich gegenseitige
beeinflussung und rücksichtnahme zu
machen
das ist richtig aber mit diesen
missionarischen ansatz andere dazu zu
zwingen die politik die wir machen
nachzumachen das halte ich für
unvertretbar unter freunden wir haben
genug baustellen die wir noch lösen
müssen
da ist die endlagerung die finanzierung
über den can vor der eine gute arbeit
macht und gute ergebnisse mit dem
angelegten geld erzeugt und ich will
auch noch darauf hinweisen
wir haben in der sechzehnten
atomgesetznovelle ansprüche von firmen
regeln sollen die auf die produktion von
strom verzichten müssen
wir haben dieses gesetz gemacht wir
haben damals unter großen bauchschmerzen
das gemacht wenn ich an die debatte
erinnern darf die wir geführt haben und
das verfassungsgericht hat dieses gesetz
für nicht existent erklärt
ich erwarte von dem umweltministerium
dass sie sehr schnell diese fragen lösen
bevor dieses jahr zu ende geht
ich wünsche dem bmw dabei viel glück
mehr glück als beim letzten mal wo ich
gemeint habe das problem wird nicht
gelöst und
nicht gelöst jetzt ist es an der zeit
und ich wünsche ihnen viel glück dabei
frau ministerin schulze vielleicht sagt
dir dass jemand dieses problem zu lösen
danke für die aufmerksamkeit kollege
möhringen
auch können dass sie haben erkannt dass
es manchmal von nachteil vielleicht ein
vorteil ist wenn man den zwischenruf
wegen der maske nicht verstehen könnt
ihr beim letzten beiden zwischenrufen
die was gedankens war damals abgenommen
so dass die schriften wurden
schriftführer zwischenrufer blockieren
können frau kollegin lötzsch hat mit
einer kräftigen stimme wie es bei den
linken typisch ist darauf hingewiesen
dass noch weiter vorne sitzen können so
nächster gegner ist der kollege dr
rainer kraft hfg fraktion
[Applaus]
särge der präsident werde kollegen und
jährlich grüßt das murmeltier könnte man
sagen
wie jedes jahr instrumentalisiert die
grüne fraktion die 20.000 todesopfer des
turbo erwähnt und auf antrag der grünen
vorsitzenden wir haben sie gerade gehört
war eigentlich gestern an der
öffentlichen anhörung im umweltausschuss
geplant zum thema fukushima erneut also
hätten die opfer des erdbebens und der
tsunami-flutwelle ausgeblendet werden
sollen
aber dazu kam erst gar nicht in der
grund ist beschämend denn eine fachliche
expertise einer geladenen experten hat
der ausschuss vorsitzenden und den
anderen ob locken nicht gepasst
vorgeschlagen war jared in tommys
professor thomas hat bahnbrechende
arbeiten an strahlung scherben am
menschlichen gewebe vorher vorzuweisen
sie hält einen lehrstuhl für molekulare
pathologie einer medizinischen fakultät
ist imperial college in london
sie hat oft in fukushima besucht um
maßgeblich am aufbau der tschernobyl gwb
datenbank mitgewirkt und vor zwei wochen
wurde professor tom ist als officer auf
dem most excellent order of the british
empire ausgezeichnet
meine damen und herren wir reden also
nicht im gegensatz zu diversen bezahlten
ngo stimmungsmache die üblicherweise von
den linken vollzogen geladen werden
sondern wir reden hier von einer echten
experte und dass das eine
ausschussvorsitzende im deutschen
bundestag mit übrigen abläufen eine
öffentliche anhörung absagt weil eine
fachliche expertise nicht passt ist ein
skandal
überraschend ist das alles nicht wir
haben uns hier drin ja schon viel zu
sehr daran gewöhnt in der praxis dass
man sich hier mit stichwortgeber und ja
sagern umgibt und es ist gerade mal drei
wochen her dass wir hier im deutschen
bundestag ihr von diesem pult aus
darüber den unseligen einfluss der
politik auf die wissenschaft geredet
haben
nichts deutet derzeit auf eine
abhängigkeit der wissenschaftler von der
politik hin so sprach damals gesprächen
oder die rednerin de und jungs
fraktionen frau mann ist und selten
selten ist eine rede so dermaßen
vorgeführt worden denn genau zeitgleich
zu ihrer rede
der bayerische ministerpräsident ein
mitglied des bayerischen ethikrates
hinaus geworfen weil in dessen fachliche
kroner meinung nicht gepasst hat
und in den folgenden drei wochen gab es
weitere fälle der göttinger
polizeipräsident wurde in den
vorzeitigen ruhestand versetzt grund er
hatte sich kritisch gegenüber der krone
maßnahmen den niedersächsischen
landesregierung geäußert und professor
fällt wird nicht erneut in den rat der
wirtschaftsweisen ernannt weil der spd
und vize kanzler scholz seine fachliche
expertise zur schuldenbremse nicht
gefällt gefällt der in der spd bleiben
wir dabei kollege riess bild sagt mir
damals ein diskussion vor drei wochen
zitat kunst und wissenschaft forschung
und lehre sind frei
dies ist ein artikel 5 des grundgesetzes
geschriebene abwehrrecht gegenüber
staatlichen eingriffen ist auch
erfahrung aus der nazizeit zitat ende
also welche erfahrungen wurden ihm
gezogen wenn ministerpräsident pistorius
und vizekanzler scholz experten
rauswerfen bei ihnen ihre fachliche
meinung nicht gefällt und der gipfel der
heuchelei wie immer ist von ihnen der
krise tatsächlich über zehn jahre
fukushima und kernenergie und ich will
das was sie aus ihrer sicht zu recht an
tragen aber das ist ein anderes thema
würden sie freundlicherweise zur sache
kommen herr präsident wir reden auch
über die gestrige anhörung zum thema
fukushima die abgesagt worden ist durch
den doch die aktionen der vorsitzende
aber gut positiv politikwissenschaft
nicht instrument instrumentalisieren
sagte ihr kollege kai gehring in der
diskussion vor drei wochen aber sie die
grünen haben mit der absage einer
fokussierung des gesund genau das getan
sie ist momentan ihren wissenschaft und
forschung grundsätzlich und sie sagen
grundsätzlich nur genehme selbsternannte
experte aus die grünen blasen die
jenseits aller fakten er deckel
horrorszenarien an die wand malen um
angst und panik zu verbreiten
als folge und mit unterstützung der
abgeordneten stimmt dann eine meute von
kohlegegner den bundestag und fassen wir
zusammen jeder ihre anträge der
vergangenen zehn jahre der sich mit
fukushima beschäftigt hat hat die
verheerenden folgen des togo erdbebens
und
desto nahm ist völlig ignoriert die
opfer dieser katastrophe 20.000 menschen
leben werden von ihnen den grünen jahr
für jahr in ekel erregender widerwärtige
art und weise instrumentalisiert und
dafür sollten sie sicher vielen dank
herr kollege kraft wie gut die kollegin
kotting-uhl möchte auf antrag der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen eine
kurze version starten ich lasse das zu
frau kollegin kotting-uhl bitte ich
danke ihnen herr präsident und ich weiß
wie schwierig das ist in diesen späten
abendstunden dann immer noch mal was
zusätzlich ist aber ich möchte doch die
anderen bisschen informieren was der
grund für die absage war in der tat wir
wollten zu zehn jahren fukushima einen
blick werfen nach japan wie die
situation dort es hatten uns geeinigt
auf ein tableau gemeinsame
sachverständiger die af.de wollte eine
eigene sachverständige und die frau
thomas die herr kraft nun erwähnt hat
von ihr berichtet hat was er nicht
ausgeführt hat ist dass diese dame der
meinung ist dass sich ergibt aus ihren
wissenschaftlichen forschungen dass an
den menschen in tschernobyl die von der
fukushima von der tschernobyl
katastrophe getroffen waren von der
export strahlenexposition keine schäden
festzustellen sind dass also ein
atomarer gau sozusagen sozial und
gesellschaftsvertrag lich ist und diese
botschaft wollte ich an einem jahrestag
von fukushima nicht aus dem deutschen
bundestag heraus setzen
herr kollege dr kraft sie haben jetzt
das recht zur erwiderung auch zwei
minuten sehr geehrte frau kotting uhl
sie haben schon wieder getan schon
wieder instrumentalisieren sie hier
opfer und ihre ausführung sind komplett
falsch wenn sie die arbeiten von frau
professor thomas erfolg hätten sie hat
selbstverständlich auch langzeitfolgen
von tschernobyl festgestellt dass heißt
sie sehen mit der arbeiten von
photonisch überhaupt gar nicht vertraut
und wenn wir auf ihre art auf ihre
anträge auf die titel ihre anträge die
inhaltliche ihre anträge kommen
dort steht dem fukushima gestern mit der
titel der anhörung mehrere fukushima
gewesen niemals hat sich eine ihre
anträge mit dem togo erdbeben
auseinandergesetzt niemals hat sich
einer mit der verbesserung vom
christentum beschäftigt oder mit
frühwarnsystemen von erbeben sie haben
immer aus ideologischen gründen
ausschließlich immer auch fukushima
abgezogen
sie haben diese 20.000 menschen immer
instrumentalisiert ihre
bundestags-vizepräsidentin hat das des
öfteren schon mal leichtfertig
durcheinander gebracht aber und sie
werden auch zitiert in ostfriesischen
kuriert dass sie einmal gesagt haben
dass in fukushima 16.000 menschen ums
leben gekommen sind
vielen dank
doch der kraft nächste rednerin ist die
kollegin doktor nina scheer spd fraktion
und auf ihrem weg wenn ich noch
mitteilen der kohlekraft es gibt nicht
ihre bundestags-vizepräsident sondern
die präsident wies man seinen sind die
präsident des gesamten distanz
[Applaus]
das habe ich jetzt phonetisch nicht der
stadt sachen ihren dialekt
wahrscheinlich frau doktor sie haben den
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn jetzt hier
im raum steht dass die erwähnung und die
fokussierung des atomaren gaus und
unfalls vom ku fukushima eine
verharmlosung gegenüber den anderen
schäden wären dann die da auch an
menschen opfern und tsunami schäden zu
verzeichnen sind dann ist das einfach
falsch und das ist auch wiederum
unwürdig gegenüber all der den opfern
der komplett katastrophe es ist das mit
20 wieder abrutschen
sie wollen wieder nur verharmlosen die
wollen die atomenergie folgeschäden
verharmlosen und wenn nicht er wer vor
ein paar tagen in den noch einmal den
sehr aufschlussreichen bericht im ersten
deutschen fernsehen gesehen hat er
nochmal daran erinnerte was vor zehn
jahren passiert das hat auch der
tagesthemen sprecher von damals aus
tokio heraus auch gesagt und das
wiedergegeben man hat ja zuerst auf den
tsunami geschaut man hat erst auf die
folgen des tsunamis geschaut und in dem
moment wo klar war was das mit den
atomreaktoren macht da war dann
tatsächlich der focus angesichts dieser
dramatik auf dieser situation deswegen
uns hier im haus insgesamt zu
unterstellen dass man denen auch schon
anderweitig nicht gerechnet es einfach
zynisch
es lenkt wieder nur ab von denen fragen
die heute zu zehn jahren fukushima in
der tat auch in frage stehen es ist toll
man arbeite ich erwähnt worden es sind
viele opfer sowohl tsunami bedingt als
auch unmittelbar auf grund der
reaktorkatastrophen und es gibt es gibt
es im deutschen bundestag ist es möglich
auch dass man zwischenrufe macht wenn
der mann habe promis gefühl man kann es
mal luft holen und kriegt schon wieder
worte also gut ich versuche das
schicksal teilen sie mit vielen hat man
an der orgel ist das schicksal ja das
schicksal der gemeinschaft ihr also ich
wollte auch die auf die situation zurück
kommen auch im zusammenhang mit den
krebsraten die massiv steigen und da
gibt es auch jüngste berichte von ärzten
vor ort den sie ja vielleicht dann
wirklich auch bei glauben schenken
können die davon sprechen dass die
krebsrate von kindern die unter
schilddrüsenkrebs dann leiden um das 20
bis 50 fache nach oben gegangen ist ich
habe nicht jetzt weitere zeit war ich
auch viele andere punkte aufholen möchte
aber alleine die den respekt vor den
opfern gebührt es doch dass sie nicht
ständig durch zwischenrufe diese
schreckliche dramatik relativieren
ich würde
als zweiten punkt dann aber auch die
atomenergie situation weltweit eingehen
und zwar ist unser doch schon auch
aufrütteln dass die gesamtinvestition in
atomenergie dass die eben doch deutlich
in den letzten jahrzehnten
zurückgegangen sind waren wir einfach
erkannt hat es ist mit blick auf die
risiken mit blick auf die
gesamtgesellschaftlichen kosten einfach
nicht mehr zu rechtfertigen es ist nicht
mehr opportun
deswegen haben wir zurzeit weltweit 31
milliarden us dollar investition in
haltung in der gdm gegenüber stehen aber
von der 38 us-dollar windenergie und 100
1 32 us-dollar 19
da die einfach nur mal in der
größenordnung in den raum zu stellen ja
aber
demgegenüber und das muss uns auch zu
denken geben forschungsausgaben die
nicht unbedingt dies widerspiegeln also
so gibt es forschungsausgaben die
weltweit gesehen immer noch 22 prozent
in atomenergie bedeuten dem die immer
nur 15 prozent in erneuerbare energien
8% in fossile und auch in deutschland
gibt es über die verflechtungen mit ita
und andere dinge in dieser richtung auch
immer noch jährlich 138 millionen euro
die wir da hinein geben und man muss
schauen dass das in der europäischen
union die hälfte aller
forschungsausgaben ausmacht sich anita
zu beteiligen und an den weiteren atom
projekten und das ist etwas was ich
denke ist heutzutage nicht mehr in dem
maß spiegelt auch nicht die
investitionen die welt getätigt hier
muss eine wende ein
hier muss auch eine überarbeitung des
euratom vertrages her weil das nicht
mehr zeitgemäße und ständig eine falsche
ausstrahlungswirkung auch in die
investitionen und die forschungen gibt
im übrigen hat mich reifer verharmlost
der welt dramatische bedrohungspotenzial
für terroristische angriffe auch von der
situation im umgang mit atomkraftwerken
ausgeht und muss es auch zu denken geben
dass die laufzeit von atomkraftwerken
weil es eben zu unwirtschaftlich ist ein
neues hin zu investieren immer länger
wird und inzwischen schon bei ungefähr
durchschnittlich 35 jahre liegt und ihr
älter sie werden desto anfälliger sind
sie und desto größer ist die bedrohung
auch die von atomkraftwerken ausgeht und
es ist auch richtig dass wir uns in der
koalition auch dies zur aufgabe gemacht
haben in einer von zwei atomgesetze
wellen die in diesen dieser
legislaturperiode noch mindestens
anstehen dann dort eben auch nochmal
sich der sache zu widmen wie es denn mit
dem schutz vor terroristischen angriffen
bestellt ist absetzen punkt richtig
immer noch eingehen wir bleiben noch
eine halbe minute auf die atom
verflechtung die zwischen
atomenergienutzung und atomwaffen
besteht und sie besteht einfach
definitiv und wird viel zu selten
thematisiert
ausgangspunkt waren der nach dem zweiten
waren im zuge des zweiten weltkriegs und
der entwicklung der atombombe 50
milliarden us dollar
die investiert wurden von eisenhower in
manhattan programm hunderttausend
menschen waren damals beschäftigt und
das war die stunde null der
atomenergienutzung das zu verleugnen
wäre falsch das bedeutet aber auch dass
die damals angelegte verpflichtung für
uns heute die mit aufgabe darstellt
immer beides zu denken ohne atomenergie
beendigung wird es keine beendet
der atomwaffen nutzen geben und ohne
ausstieg aus atom waffen wird es auch
keinen gelingenden atomenergie ausstieg
geben diesen sollte ist mein letzter
freund in dieser debatte aber wirklich
an der zeit zeichen der aufgabe zu uns
aber dann stellte vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat die kollegin judith
skudelny für die fdp-fraktion frau
präsidentin meine damen und herren liebe
frau die nur sie haben heute hier und in
ausschuss das richtige gemacht als in
ihrem antrag sie haben nämlich dieses
reaktorunglücks von fukushima
eingeordnet in der dreifach katastrophe
im ausschuss haben sie es noch ein
bisschen präziser gemacht sie haben
gesagt es ist eine dreifach katastrophe
von dem ein teil eine naturkatastrophe
ist aber das reaktorunglück etwas ist
aus dem wir lernen können
ganz ehrlich dieser teil fehlt
vollständig in den schriftlichen
ausführungen ihres antrags und das macht
diesen antrag leider menschlich gesehen
nicht so gut wie er hätte sein können
noch mehr
noch mehr aber hat mich tatsächlich ihre
argumentation verwundert gegenüber den
kernkraft befürwortung und da kann ich
mich meinem vorredner von der cdu nur
anschließen
die einzigen gründe die für sie zählen
wie sie sich vorstellen können ist macht
ihr naivität und bestechlichkeit und
wenn man sich vor augen führt über wen
sie da sprechen da sind demokratien
dabei befreundete staaten sie reden über
japan frankreich
sie können doch nicht ausgehen davon
dass die einzige krönung der intelligenz
die grünen fraktion im deutschen
bundestag
ganz ehrlich andere aktion haben auch
viele menschen und das was wir
formulieren es schlicht und ergreifend
arrogant und ihr antrag ist damit keine
anhand reiche ein lehrer die kernenergie
befürworten die vielleicht eine
handreichung dazu brauchen andere
energieerzeugungsform und andere formen
für besser zu befinden sie ist ein
faustschlag ins gesicht derer und dazu
geeignet jegliche diskussion und
argumentation und kommunikation ein ende
zu setzen und das ist das letzte was wir
im bereich der kernenergie und
sicherheit brauchen ein beispiel davon
haben sie selber genannt nämlich das
wasser einlassen denn dem pazifik und
dann sehen wir es gibt technische
lösungen dazu die technischen lösungen
sind nur aufgrund der menge des wassers
nicht einfach umzusetzen und diese
technischen lösung da können wir
vielleicht eine hilfestellung leisten
aber würden sie jemanden um hilfe und
kooperation und zusammenarbeit bitten
wir sie für naiv bestechlich und
machtgierig wir brauchen ein
partnerschaftliches miteinander um die
sicherheit auf der welt zu erhöhen
und dieser antrag ist mit sicherheit
kein beitrag dazu
[Applaus]
beim lesen ihres antrags hat gute und
schlechte seiten aber die inhalte treten
leider völlig in den hintergrund der
arrogante ton und die überheblichkeit
die sich hierdurch spiegelt stehen
leider gottes im vordergrund und
deswegen werden auch die guten argumente
von den flüchtigen personen nicht gehört
werden
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege ralph lenkert
für die fraktion gewickelt sehr geehrte
frau präsidentin kolleginnen und
kollegen am 11 märz 2011 ereignete sich
eine verheerende katastrophe in japan
ein extremes erdbeben der stärke 9 traf
die ostküste der dadurch ausgelöste
tsunami der stärkste seit 400 jahren
überspülte beide küstenbereiche über
20.000 menschen verloren ihr leben
städte und dörfer wurden dem erdboden
gleichgemacht
zu dem menschlichen leid und zu den
zerstörungen kam dann noch die
radioaktive verseuchung durch den super
gau des atomkraftwerkes fukushima
daiichi über 450.000 menschen mussten
evakuiert werden
bis heute können viele menschen trotz in
solche maßnahmen nicht in ihre heimat
zurückkehren
die menschen der region leben seitdem
mit der furcht vor zukünftigen
krebserkrankung schon heute steigt die
zahl der fehlgeburten und missbildungen
bei neugeborenen millionen kubikmeter
kontaminierter böden müssen dauerhaft
sicher verwahrt werden unmengen
verseuchten wassers trat in die umwelt
aus oder lagern in tanks bitter ist die
menschengemachte radioaktive verseuchung
hätte vermieden werden können wenn der
betreiber die japanischen vorgaben
eingehalten hätte nach denen das
atomkraftwerk auf erdbeben stärke acht
hätte ausgelegt werden sollen
der betreiber tepco hatte die reaktoren
nur auf erdbeben stärke 7 ausgelegt
historische aufzeichnungen belegen dass
in der region fukushima bereits tsunamis
von 15 meter höhe gegeben hatte in den
verhandlungen mit den aufsichtsbehörden
war es apple gelungen die tsunami
schutzanlagen nur für fünf meter
tsunamis auszulegen
diese frage dieser verheerende tsunami
hat im bereich des atomkraftwerkes eine
höhe
und 14 ein benachbartes atomkraftwerk
ausgelegt und gebaut für erdbeben stärke
8 mit einer schutzmauer gegen 15 meter
tsunamis überstand erdbeben und tsunami
es war das profitstreben das zur
katastrophe führte umgerechnet 160
milliarden wird der rückbau des
havarierten atomkraftwerkes kosten über
60 milliarden euro gruppen an den
schädigungen bereits bezahlt hinzu
kommen milliardenkosten für die
kontaminationen und der sichere verwarnt
des radioaktiv verseuchten materials und
des verseuchten wassers
und dies alles bezahlt nicht von
unternehmen sondern vom steuerzahler
es wird immer naturkatastrophen geben
die niemand erwartete die stärker
ausfallen als berechnet aber es gibt
eine möglichkeit das leid und die kosten
durch atom katastrophen zukünftig zu
vermeiden
den endgültigen ausstieg aus der
atomenergienutzung und das beenden des
euro atom vertrag
ich danke allen kolleginnen und kollegen
des 17 deutschen bundestages
die im angesicht von fukushima in
erinnerung an tschernobyl den deutschen
atomausstieg beschlossen haben es war
ein richtiger schritt für mehr
sicherheit von menschlichen und
technischen versagen können wir nicht
geschützt werden unnötige risiken sollte
man vermeiden wenn man klug ist vielen
dank
die rede dass kollegen michael kiessling
für die cdu/csu-fraktion nehmen wir zu
protokoll ich schließe die aussprache